welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the latest trailer for marvel
chongqi in the legend of the ten rings
revealed fighting in this mcu tournament
her freaking abomination from the
incredible hulk and we thank
wong from doctor strange answering his
own question
what you wanted more and we actually do
get more with a dragon
i'm gonna break down this trailer frame
by frame for all the details that you
might have missed
why abomination looks different now and
why are single name sorcerer slayer is
in the ring
let's go throughout my life
the ten rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day
you have to show me you are strong
enough to carry them
we open on the voice and arm of win woo
aka marvel villain the mandarin head of
the ten rings and this is the real
mandarin not either of those
phonies in iron man 3 because we know
from the short all hail the king that
there is a real mandarin and he's really
pissed
off that people keep using his name now
the 10 rings in the comics are mystical
alien technology mcluhan tech each with
a different power
stolen by the mandarin from alien
wreckage and really belonging to the
alien dragon fin fang boom but
here in the movie they have been
reconceived as wrist bracelets which is
really a clever move by marvel that
avoids comparison to the infinity stones
and evokes the iron strength bracelets
of chinese martial arts like hungar
now i have theorized that the rings
could be larger to fit giant
dragon fingers but footage in this
trailer confirms that the rings actually
change
size to fit the wielder's arm anyway
similar to the ring and lord of the
rings
a black flag shows us the 10 rings logo
updated from its past
mcu sightings with these crossed weapons
being the hook
swords or tiger swords so maybe each
regional chapter of the 10 rings has
regionally appropriate melee weapons
within each of these rings are chinese
characters this is ancient calligraphy
known as seal script the top
is quan meaning power or authority which
is actually part of the name of the
emperor's during the three kingdoms
period clockwise to the right
is lee meaning physical strength or
power the third ring is
zhong so sorry about my pronunciations
on all this it means
strong or robust actually a lot of these
translate to some version of strength or
power it's kind of like the ten rings of
flicks
the fourth ring is wei meaning
extraordinary magnificent or great the
fifth is
ga meaning hero heroic or outstanding
person the sixth at the bottom is
she which means power or influence also
associated with the male genitals and
continuing clockwise to the left
the seventh is hong meaning large
extensive great in the literal sense
the eighth is meaning powerful or grand
also
refers to things that are male the ninth
is kyang meaning strong or powerful
and the tenth is wei meaning pomp or
power and we see the rings in action
from when wu on horseback magically
suspended off his
arms wielded kind of like maces or
slingshots
that zip around and physically hit stuff
which give these a much more tangible
lethality to them let's move on
you are a product of all who came before
you
the legacy of your family you are your
mother
and whether you like it or not okay here
we see this rocky island
and if you look closely this red
textured portal skates upon the other
shot by xiangnan xiao ling
chong chi and katie now shanxi later
duels his father
for the rings in front of this portal
and it's interesting how its red texture
matches shang chi's red wardrobe as if
this portal could lead to a mystical
realm where shang chi acquires his new
attire now we see shangchi's feet
land before this gate as if he leapt
across the water to land there the
cinematographer of this movie is bill
pope known for his camera work on the
matrix
and shang chi sticking the land in here
does kind of look like morpheus's epic
landing in that jump program
jiangnan talks about shangchi's family
including his mother
zheng li we see his mother training him
as a boy in this shrine before this
wooden engraving actually later this
same location has a candlelit shrine to
i think the same woman so zheng li might
have died when chongqi was still a young
boy leaving it to his abusive father to
raise him instead
notice how the flashbacks to his
training under his father all tinted in
blue whereas those with his mother are
tinted in gold reflecting the color
scheme of the dueling magic between wen
wu
and shang qi when they fight then a shot
at the tin rink's courtyard you can see
the logo on the floor and on the banners
showing warriors training with the hook
swords while in the background you can
see when woo sitting on his throne
that's from the other shot that we saw
him in
in the previous trailer but then to win
was right is another
hard to make out the person's face
though i wonder if this could be death
dealer
leashing lin before he put on his mask
next clip you are
also your father
here shang chi spars and then straight
up fights with death dealer who in the
comics is a torturer working for fu
manchu
shanxi's father the editing here sinks
death dealer's strike with young chongqi
blocking it further out but then older
shang chi lets it get closer to his eye
meaning here death dealer is no longer
holding back
as they fight on this high-rise moving
on i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
here the cage fighting bar that we keep
coming back to gets swarmed by ten rings
warriors notice how their hook swords
are all glowing blue
the same color of the radiated energy
from the ten rings when when woo use
them
as death dealer throws the explosive
dagger into the window notice blown back
from that explosion outside on the
scaffolding is both shangshi
and xi ling meaning zeidling is not
firmly on the side of the mandarin in
the death dealer but might rather be
another estranged exiled child
like shanxi next clip glad i was right
here's just a criminal who murders
people
be careful how you speak to me boy so
here young shanxi witnesses his father
murder
someone in this club you can see in the
mirror when we use the rings to grab
that guy either by the neck or the
shoulders and then hurl him into the
glass wall and then
right in front of his boy aims those
rings down the guy's head to plug him
yikes moving on
i thought i could change my name start a
new life
but i could never so xiangnan chose some
of her powers
it looks like she's an airbender within
this dome and notice at the base of it
is a wavy serpentine body
most likely representing the dragon that
chongqi later encounters actually that
sea dragon also can be seen on that
shrine wall engraving as
it leaks water perhaps suggesting a link
between this dragon
and chongchi's maternal ancestry as
razor fist attacks chongqi on the bus
right behind them recording it all is
once again comedian zack cherry
who played the duo-flip guy in
spider-man homecoming and in a bit with
stephen colbert campaigned to get a
spin-off marvel film of his own but
before we continue thanks to bright
sellers for sponsoring this video i like
to drink wine but
i'm really not an expert frankly i'm
always a little unsure whenever i have
to say the words like uh sauvignon or
pinot out loud in front of people but
lucky for me there is bright cellars
they use a quiz to determine your taste
preferences and then they show you a
list of the top six wines you're most
likely to enjoy from around the world
they
educate you about wine along the way to
help you find your new favorites and if
you like your recommendations and want
to try them they'll ship them straight
to your door
each bottle comes with an educational
card with tips about serving and pairing
so here's the box i got there's four of
them in here
here are the cards you get they show you
the different flavors in there
and then like good types of food and
occasions that you'd want to
drink it with let's see folk and fable
folk and fable so this
is a red blend and it's crafted in
california 2019
i'm gonna focus love it i've gotten a
few boxes from brightsellers so far
based on my ratings they sent me these
new wines and based on how much i
enjoyed the last ones i'm gonna love
these i might not become a sommelier
but i don't need a sommelier to tell me
what good wine i'm gonna like
bright sellers helps me teach myself and
bright sellers is giving our followers
60 off their first four bottle box
that's such a great deal so follow the
link and take the quiz and get started
moving on escape his shadow
my son you can't run from your past
so when wu fights either as or young lee
who dodges the rings as they whizz past
her
a bit more of bill pope's matrix camera
work evoking neo dodging the bullets
and then this interesting looking battle
in this mystical setting where modern 10
ring soldiers fight
warriors in red as a huge ass food dog
swipes one now these mythological beasts
are often seen guarding buddhist temples
two actually appear at the courtyard
gate in the tin rings compound as they
all bow to them
notice how the red warrior shields and
staffs glow with this
golden energy contrasting the blue
win-woo-linked glow of the ten rings
warriors and i am wondering if these
ancient warriors could be
the true heirs the rightful possessors
of the
ten rings these are the people that win
woo could have stolen the rings from
maybe even a group shanghi's mother
could have come from and now their realm
gateway
is confined to this forbidden island an
island guarded by the dragon and
throughout this movie we'll see shanxi
reconnecting with those roots in order
to get his power which is why in the
standoff with his father he now wears
that same color as these other warriors
and wields golden magic against his
father's blue magic
chongqi and xiling fight in this bar and
while breaking down the previous trailer
i pointed out that that star in the left
on the background was not cap's shield
but actually looks more like the
crescent moon in the star of the
magipore flag matchboard being the
southeastern asian country that we saw
in the falcon the winter soldier more on
why that could be important in a bit but
let's move on
is this what you wanted
here be dragons so according to cineloo
thin fang fume from marvel comics is not
going to be in this movie but a toilet
to describe this dragon as
the great protector which might be why
shang chi doesn't seem too afraid of it
but what is it protecting well as i
mentioned that shrine linked the dragon
with water and its form outlined the
garden dome
i'm wondering if this dragon is actually
protecting that immortal realm
and that that is the place that when woo
wants to access but he has been
banished and forbidden he's been on
their [ __ ] list for stealing their 10
rings but there is some deeper greater
magic that he wants to have perhaps
immortality that could be why he's
hosting this tournament something he
might try to rig with his own offspring
to grant him
access to this realm is this what you
wanted but what he doesn't account for
is that the apple has fallen fall from
the tree and that chongqi will have a
friendlier connection with this realm
and its dragon protector maybe even this
dragon could have a connection with his
mother's soul and we see wen wu and
chung chi
in this tug of war right in front of
this portal and notice how where their
energy tethers meet
one ring glows golden on win woo side
while another glows blue on chongqi's
side kind of like they're reaching past
each other
to try to pull the other in and then
look in the upper right corner there's
some winged creature flapping around
maybe a little dragon
and we saw the same creature back in the
other trailer flying around in that
mystical realm so yeah i am thinking
this is a gateway to there and then on
to the final clip
you got this
thank you yes so apparently one bracket
matchup in this movie's fighting
tournament is gonna be abomination
versus wong now we know it's abomination
because the youtube captions say
abomination roars and we're pretty sure
it's wong because benedict wong and
simulu were spotted together during
production for this movie and yeah this
looks very much like wong or at least a
sun double who looks just like him
so recap on abomination mio blonsky
played by tim roth last seen in the
incredible hulk in 2008 when hulk
defeated him in harlem in the year since
marvel head kevin feige has hinted that
abomination was locked in a prison
somewhere in aegis's shield they said
that he was locked up in alaska and then
last december kevin feige confirmed that
abomination would return on the marvel
disney plus series she-hulk so notice
how abomination now has greener skin
he's got these face fins super stretchy
pants
this is closer to his comic appearance
than the design in the 2008 film if this
fighting club is magipur we know from
the falcon winter soldier that that was
a place where the power broker was
funding super soldier serum research
and blonsky was initially powered with
super soldier serum before he took
banner's blood to become abomination so
maybe this guy continued to receive
dosages of different serum cocktails
that
changed his appearance into this maybe
thunderbolt ross eager to get a chance
at the 10 rings
offers blonsky a chance to fight for his
freedom as the us government's champion
in this tournament and then when he
inevitably fails maybe his case will get
taken up by attorney jennifer walters
who defends government test subjects
while reigning in her clients whenever
necessary but there's also a chance that
this could tie in with the thunderbolts
with val from the falcon winter soldier
assembling a team of anti-heroes
including john walker
and rumor has it someone from black
widow abomination could be that team's
muscle now wong would have a chance in
this fight because we saw him use a
sling ring portal to sever the hand of
kul obsidian who has a strength profile
similar to hulk and therefore similar to
abomination
but maybe this fight doesn't allow
weapons apart from one's own body so
maybe no sling rings but like razorfist
could argue they're part of his body i
don't know
i theorized that the masters of the
mystic arts wanted a champion of their
own in this tournament hoping for a
chance to
get mystical artifacts out of the wrong
hands and back into theirs because we
know they're looking ahead to doctor
strange and the multiverse madness
they're gonna need some bigger guns to
face the threat of the scarlet witch
hey you can support this channel by
checking out our new loki inspired merch
options like the shirt loki out of time
at new rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter eaboss follow new
rockstars and subscribe thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you